Now, when you think of the industries
most responsible for climate change,
you probably summon up
an image of an oil rig, right?
Maybe even a coal mine
or a megafarm,
perhaps heavy engineering.
But there’s one industry
that’s never mentioned in that list
even though every other industry
depends upon it.
I’m talking about
an economic sector that makes ...
nothing.
It has no stock,
no warehouses,
no factories.
It’s entirely powered by brains,
by spreadsheets
and by PowerPoint.
Who is this mystery industry?
The professional services
of advertising and PR firms,
the big management consultancies,
the corporate lawyers and lobbyists.
Together, this sector is worth
over two trillion dollars a year.
Let’s call it the “X industry,”
where X is for influence.
Now, when it comes to climate change,
each individual firm in this sector
has the carbon footprint
probably no bigger
than your average kindergarten.
But the brainprint of the X industry
is felt everywhere.
And that’s because these problem-solvers
and storytellers act
as the grease in the wheel
of all other businesses on Earth.
And that gives the X industry
an outsize influence
on the likelihood that we reach net-zero,
or they will be one of the primary
architects of climate destruction.
Now, how?
Remember that oil rig
we imagined a moment ago?
Think about how it’s actually built.
I’ve seen this firsthand.
It takes a village of X industry
advisers to raise a rig.
First --
often,
the oil exploration proposals
are financially modeled
by one of the big constultancies.
Then the lobbying firms
push through regulatory approval,
often years, if not decades, ahead
of a single drop of oil being pumped.
Then the PR agencies,
they come in and they work
to get local communities onside.
And the legal firms
squash any legal objection.
Finally, the creative agencies
craft influence campaigns
to help sell the image of the oil industry
and to sell the product itself.
Oil companies know how to drill for oil,
but they’ve outsourced
almost everything else
to this army of publicists
and consultants,
to lawyers and to lobbyists.
We all remember the Deepwater
Horizon disaster of 2010,
when BP polluted the Gulf of Mexico
with over four million barrels of oil.
What you might not know
is that BP admitted
to spending three times as much
on promotional advertising
in the year after the disaster
than in the year before.
And arguably,
the X industry has done
a better job of cleaning up BP’s image
than BP has yet done cleaning up
the Gulf of Mexico.
(Applause)
Thank you.
Oh, come on, come on.
Is it really fair for me to hold
the X industry responsible
for the environmental impact
of their clients?
There is no official way
to do so just yet.
We recognize only three scopes
of carbon emission.
Scopes one and two:
all the direct emissions
from your fleets and your factories
and the power that you purchase.
In the UK,
the advertising association has estimated
that the entire carbon footprint
of the UK ad industry,
worth over 20 billion dollars a year,
is just 1.1 million tonnes.
1.1 million tonnes.
Now, scope three,
the third scope,
this is a bit harder.
This is all the indirect emissions
from how people use your products
or from your supply chain.
And that’s a necessary headache
for a lot of companies
to start taking control over.
But technically, the X industry
barely moves the dial here either.
That’s why I believe that the X industry
needs a new scope X,
a way to account
for the emissions of influence.
Now the --
(Applause)
The experts at the Purpose
Disruptors network have made a start
at doing just that.
They looked at a single
advertising campaign made for Audi.
Now this campaign won one of the big
effectiveness awards in advertising.
And the car company
and their advertising agency claimed
that this single campaign
generated 1.78 billion dollars
of incremental revenue for Audi.
The ad campaign sold a lot of cars.
And if their claim is correct,
it also generated 5.1 million tonnes
of additional carbon for Audi.
So this is a one-to-five ratio
between the impact
of an entire industry --
the entire ad industry --
versus one single advertising campaign.
It is time for those of us, like me,
who work in this industry,
to take our responsibility seriously.
And that starts with being honest
about who pays our bills.
The X industry is famously
murky about that.
And so my firm in 2015 produced
the first client disclosure report.
It’s very simple.
We just disclosed our revenue
by the client industries which we serve.
I’m so pleased to say
that 170 other ad agencies,
consultancies and PR companies
have now promised to do the same.
(Applause)
But our industry is dominated
by a handful of really big consultancies
and advertising agencies,
and not one of them
have yet promised to join us.
And this really matters
because the X industry is hiring up
many of the most inventive,
creative,
knowledgeable
and influential minds that humanity has.
And those are the exact
same skills that we need
to change the course of climate change.
Now we need all of that X industry talent
to stop serving destruction
and start serving solutions.
And if you work in the X industry,
you’re probably beginning to feel
a little bit uncomfortable right now.
Good.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
I want you to ask yourself:
Are you selling your talent
to the right people?
Are you serving the causes
of climate change or the solutions to it?
And are you using all that vaunted ability
to influence your clients
or just to influence their critics?
This must be the solutions decade,
and we’re nearly two years into our window
to change our systems
towards climate justice,
towards clean energy,
circular systems,
sustainable and equitable lifestyles.
This solutions decade desperately requires
really good-quality financial modeling.
It requires a really strong
legal framework,
great research.
It really needs public support.
It needs the right regulatory rules.
And it needs creative storytelling,
and that’s what my X industry
could deliver.
This year, I changed my job title
to “Chief Solutionist”.
I changed it to constantly remind myself
of the job that needs doing.
Because as an X industry leader myself,
I can either serve
the solutions every day,
or by default,
I’m serving destruction.
There is no middle ground here.
There must be no
carefully worded rationales.
And the X industry can no longer pretend
it can remain neutral.
Now if we do that,
perhaps we could become
a league of solutionists
and shift all of this creativity,
inventiveness,
knowledge and influence
towards fixing climate change.
And then this invisible
and intangible
and incredibly influential X industry
can finally stop being part of the problem
and become part of the solution.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)